Okay, good morning. So,
let us do an overview of the history
of the ancient Israelites.
Okay?
Um
from about 1010, the year 1010 BCE,
until
uh 586.
Um this is what what is referred to as
the first temple
uh period.
So, remember the nation of Israel is
created
by King David, and it's a coalition
of different tribes, different cultures,
different religions.
And what makes this nation possible are
two things.
The first thing is the charisma of
David. The second is
the tremendous literary power and genius
of the Yahwist,
uh the individual who wrote the first
stories
of the Bible, Adam and Eve, the
patriarchs, Moses.
Okay?
Um
and what centers or unifies this nation
is
the first temple in Jerusalem.
Remember uh to create centralized
authority, uh David and Solomon, his son
Solomon, they build a temple
where everyone has to come in order to
make sacrifices to Yahweh. Okay? So, the
first temple is the house of Yahweh.
All right?
And at this point, we can there are
certain characteristics about this new
religion or this new nation. Okay?
And again, um I will have to
oversimplify for the sake of clarity.
Okay? So, the first thing I would say
about this new religion is
um it's polytheistic.
Okay? It aspires to a monotheism, but
it's only aspirational because the
reality is
it's a multi-nat- it's a multi-cultural
coalition.
And people are going to believe what
their fathers and their grandfathers
believed.
Okay? Um they may and so people at this
point have multiple faiths.
And so the religion that we refer today
as uh Judaism is only shared by an the
elite people, okay? King David, his
family, and the priests, and maybe other
uh people in the elite. Okay? Um second
thing is
it is
a monarchy, okay?
And the third thing is
this religion is an open, tolerant,
and optimistic
religion.
Because remember,
the Bible, it's really the story of two
people, Yahweh and David, forming an
everlasting friendship that becomes the
basis
for the nation of Israel. Also remember
that in um the Yahweh's understanding of
Yahweh,
Yahweh is a poet god. He's fallible,
he's sensitive, but he means good. He's
willing to grow and help the the
Israelites grow as well.
And in this religion, to show faith to
Yahweh, to
um show your devotion to Yahweh, you
must argue with him.
You must learn and go grow with him as
well. Okay, so this is a very open,
confident, generous, and optimistic uh
religion.
By the time reach the second second
temple period, okay, from 539
to 70 uh,
CE.
Okay?
539 BC to 7 uh, CE. This is called the
second temple period.
Why? Because in 586, their temple is
destroyed by the Babylonians.
Okay?
By By the time we reach this period,
the Israelites are no longer referred to
as Israelites. They're referred to as
Jews.
And the Jewish people
and the Israelites,
they share the Bible,
but in terms of culture and values, um,
they're very different.
So, at this point,
the Jewish people have become what we
call henotheistic.
Now, the henotheism
is you believe there are gods, but your
god is the best. Okay? Your god, Yahweh,
is superior to all gods, and all the
gods are false idols.
They are deceivers.
Second thing about the second second
second temple period is
it's very anti-monarch
monarchy, okay? And so, it focus on the
priesthood.
And the idea of ritual, religious
ritual.
So,
by the second second temple period,
the focus of power has shifted from the
monarchy to the priesthood. And in a
minute, I'll explain why there was this
change. Okay?
The But, the last thing
for our purposes to understand about the
culture is it's become extremely focused
on purity.
Okay? You can also say it focused on
fanatacism.
It's a very closed and conservative
culture now.
They believe their culture is the best
and they believe it's important not to
intermix with other cultures.
So, for example,
Jewish women are explicit explicitly
forbidden
to marry foreign men.
Okay?
And then
from about 100 CE onwards,
there's another transition
to the religion.
The reason why is
remember,
in the Second Temple period,
religious worship is centered around the
Second Temple.
But in 70 CE, the Romans destroyed the
temple and banished the Jews from
Jerusalem.
Um
and so this makes massive changes to the
religion after about 100 CE. That
carries um
it to the present day. The first thing
is it becomes fully monotheistic.
Okay? They only believe there's only one
God and that's it.
Second is
because there's no more temple and you
cannot no no no longer make any
sacrifices to Yahweh,
the center of authority in this religion
called Judaism are the rabbis.
And rabbis means teachers. Okay? So, the
word for this period is called
rabbinical
uh Judaism.
Okay.
In other words, the Bible becomes the
center of religious worship in Judaism.
Before, it was the temple. Now, it's the
Bible.
It's the rabbis who
interpret for you what the Bible means.
The last thing about this is the idea of
diaspora.
Diaspora just means they are now spread
out all around the world.
They are no longer in Jerusalem. They're
spread out all around the world. And as
such,
um you will have multiple strands of
Judaism because their religion now has
to interface with local culture and
local customs.
Okay.
So, this is a very broad overview about
a of a thousand years of the history of
the development of Judaism. As you can
see,
um
there are these massive cultural changes
uh about every 500 years.
And the reason why is
the historical circumstance
of the Israelites and the Jewish people
change over time.
Remember,
the Israel the state the nation of
Israel was founded as an historical
accident. It was because of the Bronze
Age collapse.
His Historically, the Levant was
controlled by a superpower either in
Anatolia or in Egypt or in Mesopotamia.
But because of the Bronze Age collapse,
um the Hittites and the Egyptians had to
retreat from the Levant, which gave
space for a localized
empire to emerge. And that's Israel.
But over time, because the Levant was so
strategically important,
empires started to take over the Levant
as a staging post for an invasion of
Egypt, okay? So, um what would happen
over time is um the Assyrians and the
Babylonians would come and conquer
uh Israel.
Also,
because the nation of Israel was
multicultural
and multilingual, it was only held
together by the personal charisma of
David. So, when he died, it was very
hard to hold the nation together.
And when his son Solomon died in in 931
BCE,
the nation of Israel was divided into
two
kingdoms. Something called the northern
kingdom Israel and then Judah.
The problem with this is
the nation of Israel is centered around
the religion.
And the religion is centered around
religious rituals in the temple.
So, and the temple was found in
Jerusalem in Judah. So, the people in
northern kingdom had to make changes to
religion. Basically, change
uh the sites of religious worship.
Okay?
Um
in 586,
the Babylonians came and destroyed
um Judah. And they burned the
like the first temple.
And the policy of the Babylonians was to
uh capture the elite
and hold them hostage in Babylonia.
And then
um send in a foreign delegation to
control the territory. Okay? And this
this is what is called the Babylonian
captivity.
And while the
uh Israelites are there,
they're trying to hold on
to the memory of who they are, okay? And
there are two
memories that sustain them in this
period. The first is the memory
of the greatness of King David. How they
were once a united monarchy under the
leadership
of David, okay? So, that's They're very
proud of that. That's what sustains
them.
The other thing that sustains them
is the Bible. The stories of the of the
Yahwehs, okay? Adam and Eve, the
patriarchs.
And because they are so focused on these
memories, and because these memories are
written down,
um they specialize the Israelites
specialize in in sexual activities.
Okay? So, in Babylon and then elsewhere,
they become very successful. They become
administrators, they become teachers,
they become intellectuals.
Okay? And they over this time will also
produce their own literature
as as they ask for people to sustain
them and to unify them.
Okay? Also at this time, what's
important to understand is
the identity as Israelite people becomes
much more concrete and much more locked
in.
Before, when they were back in Judea, in
the Levant, their identity was very
fluid. It was very open.
It was very dynamic.
But now that they are part of the
diaspora, they have left Jerusalem,
their identity becomes much more
concrete. And the analogy would be
here in China, we use simplified
Chinese.
But guess what? When you go to overseas
Chinese communities, the diaspora,
right, in Southeast Asia,
um they all use traditional Chinese
characters.
They hold on to try Chinese culture
um much more fanatically than in China.
Right? Does that make sense?
Okay? So,
a very concrete um
identity emerges during the Babylonian
captivity.
Also, what's important is
they need to if they are to survive as a
people, they need to explain
why this is happening to them.
During the Davidic the Davidic kingdom,
okay?
Um they were at the height of their
power.
And the Bible was written at a at a time
and they believe that from now on this
kingdom of David would last forever. And
that's what God promised.
So, why is it
that the northern kingdom and Judah
split? And why were they conquered by
the Assyrians and then the Babylonians?
And why have they lost their land that
God promised to them?
And the answer is because
they broke their covenant with Yahweh.
Right? It's a called covenant, a
contract. If you
the Israelite people are loyal to me,
meaning you only worship me,
then I, Yahweh, will protect you as my
chosen people.
So, if Yahweh
has abandoned us, it's because of three
reasons.
Okay? The first reason is because
um we start to worship foreign gods.
Okay? That's the first reason. Second
reason is
because we start to have kings. And our
religion does not allow kings because
the authority of kings
um contradicts the authority of Yahweh.
Okay? And the third reason is because we
broke the Ten Commandments because we
continue to sin as a people.
And the people who argue this are called
a prophets.
Okay?
So,
after the first temple period, being the
second temple period, uh the Jewish
people adopt a prophetic tradition.
They believe that
Jewish people must remain pure
to their love of God if they are to
survive as a people.
Okay?
Okay. So,
uh
They are in in Babylon captivity for
um almost 70 years, and then the
Persians conquer the Babylonians.
The Persian empire is really the first
multinational empire in human history.
And their ruler, Cyrus the Great, he is
known for being an extremely open,
tolerant, and generous ruler.
So,
he releases the Jews from Babylon and
have them return
to Jerusalem, where they will rebuild
their temple, called the Second Temple.
And this starts the beginning of the
Second Temple period.
And the Jews are so grateful that Cyrus
the Great is called the Messiah
in
their Bible. Okay, Messiah means the
anointed one, the one chosen by God to
save the Jewish people.
And Cyrus the Great is the only
foreigner
who is called Messiah in the Bible.
Cyrus the Great sponsors both the
building of the Second Temple, as well
as encourage the Jews to start the
project that we now refer to as the
Bible.
Okay? And this was led by a priest
uh named Ezra,
who was
part
um who was in Babylon, but he returned
to lose Jerusalem to
uh rejuvenate
their religion
and to start the Bible.
Okay? So, that's the very brief overview
of the history
uh of the first thousand years of
Judaism.
Any Any so far?
Are you guys clear about this?
Okay. So, what I will do now
is I'm going to focus specifically
on
this period, okay?
When Cyrus
conquered Babylon and released the Jews
to return to
um Jerusalem. Because this marks a
fundamental shift in the religion.
At this point, what will happen is the
merger of the Persian religion with the
Israelite religion, which creates a new
religion, okay? Now, the religion of the
Persians is called Zoroastrianism.
All right?
And the merger of these religions will
become the basis of a new religion that
will come to dominate the world called
Christianity.
All right?
Okay.
So, to understand this history, I will
have to first talk about the history of
Mesopotamia, okay?
So, as we discussed in class, the
history of Mesopotamia
is one of violent struggle.
Because there are many violent uh people
in this area.
And this area is the center of the
world, basically. It's where all the
trade goes through. It's very wealthy.
It's very multiethnic and multinational.
So, conflict and violence arises all the
time. Okay? So,
um you have over here a place called
Arabia.
Now, Arabia are nomad nomadic people.
Okay? And over here, you have something
called the Zagros Mountains.
Up up here is Anatolia, which is also
very wealthy.
And over here are the two rivers, okay?
The Euphrates and the Tigris. And the
city-states
are built along
the
uh two rivers.
The peop- the the nomadic the nomadic
people in the desert of Arabia and the
mountains of Zagros
are oppor- opportunistic, okay? They
will trade with you,
but they'll also raid you and steal from
you.
Okay? They'll constantly be raiding and
trading with these city-states.
What keeps them in check is these city
city-states have walls.
Okay?
As well,
these city-states will fight each other
for dominance.
Okay, because in Mesopotamia,
the the religion is people must fight
for the honor and glory of their patron
god.
What keeps the city-states from
destroying each other
is they believe that each city-state
uh,
in each city city city-state in a temple
lives a great god.
So, you can destroy the enemy's army in
the battlefield, but you can't go and
ransack the city and the temple, because
that will incur the wrath of the god.
Okay? So, there are these religious
taboos that keep the system in check.
And so, for centuries, they've been
fighting each other and struggling
against each other.
And in this process of struggle,
they will create many tremendous
innovations that will, uh, forever
change human history. For example, they
create writing.
They they create,
um,
many, uh, forms of knowledge like
mathematics and astronomy.
Okay? So, this is what considered the
cradle of civilization.
This system broke down when a king
named, uh, Lugal
Lugal
okay?
of a city-state called Umma.
Okay? And Umma's always at
is always in conflict with a city-state
called Lagash.
And Lugal Zagesi,
he is so ambitious that he's willing to
defy the gods.
He decides, "This is stupid. I keep on
attacking my enemy, but I have to
retreat
after I win because I'm afraid of
offending their god.
Well,
I'm going to test their god. I'm going
to go into Lagash, destroy the temple,
steal all their wealth so I can fund
other military
um
adventures and see if their god will
seek revenge."
Okay? So, he's breaking breaking a
taboo. He's basically It's basically
like the equivalent of
using a nuclear weapon today, okay?
So, he goes to Lagash and destroys
Lagash,
burns down the temple, steals all their
wealth,
and nothing happens. In fact, he becomes
even more successful. And he goes around
and starts slowly and slowly conquering
um the
city-states of Mesopotamia of Sumer, and
he's about to unite all the entire
region.
And now the city-states are unified in
their hatred of this person.
He has defied their temples. He has
mocked their gods.
Okay?
This creates an opportunity for another
warlord named Sargon
of Akkad.
And Sargon of Akkad is determined to
destroy Lugal Zagesi and restore the
honor and glory of the gods of
Mesopotamia.
Why is he doing this?
Because he himself has a legitimacy
problem. Okay? He was a mercenary,
and
he was part of a city-state of Kish,
okay? So he So he was supposed to be
loyal to the king of Kish, but he was
extremely ambitious and charismatic
soldier, so he did what David did, and
he usurped the throne.
And so now this creates a legitimacy
problem, because remember, in this
religion, um kings are descended from
the gods.
So now you, by usurping the throne, have
offended the gods.
So Sargon, uh his his his name means
legitimate king, by the way, okay?
Legitimate king, which tells us no one
thought he was legitimate, okay?
He decides that he will
create legitimacy by destroying
Lugal-zagesi. And he does that, okay? He
destroys like as Lugal-zagesi,
he captures him, parades him around,
and then kills him to show that he is
favored by the gods.
And by doing this, Sargon of Akkad
unifies
all of Mesopotamia, and he creates the
first world empire called the Akkadian
Empire.
Okay?
But also by doing this,
okay, by creating the first empire,
Sargon of Akkad will now unleash a cycle
of violence.
Okay?
And so, over time, everyone will have
will be forced to become more violent in
order to maintain balance. It becomes an
arms race of fear, terror, and violence.
And empires rise and fall all the time.
Okay? Again, the problem with this area
is you have extremely aggressive
nations,
and there are no natural boundaries to
protect you. So it's So even though it's
very easy for you to build an empire,
it's also very easy for you to lose the
empire.
Okay?
By 600
uh
BCE,
there are three major powers in this
region. Okay? Over here in Anatolia,
our people call them the the
uh Lydia. The the Lydians, okay? The
Lydians.
Over here
in Mesopotamia, our people will call
them the Babylonians.
And over here,
okay, are the Medians.
And they are These are three superpowers
that check and balance each other out.
They're powerful, but they're not
powerful enough to destroy each other.
Okay? Around this time
will emerge a new
power
centered called the Persians.
They are led by a great king named Cyrus
the
Great, okay?
Um he is considered to be the greatest
ruler in human history.
Alexander the Great saw him as a role
model.
When Alexander the Great
um invaded Persia,
and he saw that the tomb of Cyrus the
Great had been uh desecrated or uh
abandoned,
he was furious, and he stopped his
campaign to make sure the tomb was
renovated and returned to its former
glory. If you go to Iran today, you can
still visit the tomb of Cyrus the Great.
Because throughout history, everyone
had a high opinion of him, okay? Even
the Greeks thought he was fabulous.
His own people, of course, loved him.
So, for the longest time before
Alexander the Great and Julius Caesar,
he was considered
the greatest ruler in human history.
Okay?
So, but the problem is because we don't
have access to writing
the writing, we have absolutely we know
very little about him, okay? Here's what
we do know about him.
He was in charge
he was king of a local people called the
Persians
who were of course are descended from
the Elamite.
Okay? So, they use horse archers in
their warfare. Over time, he's able to
conquer the Medes.
King Croesus of the Lydians saw this as
an opportunity
to conquer the Medes as well. So, he
attacks.
But, Cyrus the Great defeats him,
okay? So, now Cyrus the Great is in
charge of two empires.
What he does next is revolutionary in
Mesopotamia. Instead of parading them
around
like the the captive kings around
and executing them like Sargon of Akkad,
Cyrus the Great decides to make them
advisors
to his court.
He shows mercy. He shows clemency. He
shows forgiveness.
And this
shocks and awes the people of
Mesopotamia.
It shows Cyrus the Great is confident,
is powerful, and is favored by the gods
because he is willing to show mercy
to his enemies.
But, knowing that, what happens next is
really interesting.
The Babylonian Empire
is the last empire in Mesopotamia.
Okay? If Cyrus the Great wants to unify
Mesopotamia,
he has to conquer the Babylonians.
At this time, the Babylonians have an
internal conflict. The king and the
nobility aren't getting along. The king
wants to change the official god of
Babylon from Marduk
to Sin
because the king wants to establish his
own religious authority. So, this
creates continuous conflict eternally in
Babylon.
And normally, they would go to civil
war.
And normally, when they hear that Cyrus
the Great has conquered the Medians and
the Lydians, then they would think they
have to unify in order to defeat Cyrus
the Great.
But,
they hear that Cyrus the Great, he's
merciful,
and he's generous, and he's wise. So,
what they do is the nobility strikes a
deal with Cyrus the Great.
And
Cyrus the Great conquers Babylonia
without doing anything.
And in the the official history of Cyrus
the Great, he claims that the conquest
of Babylonia was the greatest conquest
was his greatest conquest because he did
it
through
his generosity and his mercy.
As opposed to
killing
lots and lots of people.
Okay?
And at this time, what Cyrus the Great
and the Persians realize is
if you really want to control people,
you have to use a policy called divide
and rule.
And the idea is this.
Before
these empires, the Akkadians, the
Assyrians, the Babylonians, they
believed they had to use violence and
fear to control people. But when you do
that, all you do is you anger people,
you unite them,
and force them to rebel against you.
Okay? But,
if you recognize that in each society,
there are these natural factions who are
in conflict with each other, and you're
able to balance these factions,
then they rely on you
for stability.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay, this is what we call divide and
rule.
So,
the Persians created not an empire, but
what we call a federation.
In other words, a federation is the idea
that
people choose to be part of this
federation because it benefits them.
Okay, why does it benefit them? Because,
first of all, it brings peace.
If there's a conflict, you don't fight
each other, you go to the Persians for a
conflict resolution, okay? So, it brings
peace.
Second of all,
it
brings prosperity through trade.
Okay, so the Persians create all these
roads that enable
trade within the empire.
And so, you're better off actually
trading than you are fighting.
Okay?
And third of all,
um you're able to access new knowledge
and culture through this process.
So, the Persians were the first to
create a national imperial postal
system. It was very, very clever. So,
all they did was
they set up um checkpoints throughout
the empire. And these these checkpoints
they were like hotels for postmen.
They had food, they had new clothing,
had a place to sleep. These postmen
would on their horses carry mail
throughout the empire and stop at the at
these checkpoints to rest.
Okay?
So,
the Persians showed that by
participating in this empire, you could
benefit a lot more
than if you didn't participate, and
therefore you should participate.
It's And so, it's an amazing
achievement, because remember, these
nations were at war with with each other
throughout their history.
And these are very aggressive people
with lots of religious differences. And
Cyrus the Great and his uh descendants
were able to create a system that
allowed them to work together and
prosper together.
And that's why he is remembered today
Cyrus the Great
is remembered today
as the greatest ruler of all time, okay?
In human history. No one comes second.
And also what the Jews refer to as
Messiah,
the God God's chosen, God's anointed, a
man picked by God to come to save the
human people, the human race.
So, with this federation with this
empire, what's important is the idea of
administration.
Okay? Administration.
You need administrators
who
will be
conscientious and loyal
and good people, okay?
Because remember, they are working with
local governors. So, each region is
allowed local autonomy. And each
governor is called satrap. So, they are
working with the with the satraps to
govern
the local area.
And remember, these satraps are allowed
maximum autonomy and freedom to do what
they believe. The everyone's allowed to
practice their own religion. Okay? So,
the administrators are doing is ensuring
dividing rule, right?
That there's enough internal conflict
within this region so that they're all
dependent on the empire for guidance and
authority.
These administrators have to be have to
be
um
they can't get into like bed with the
satraps. They can't be corrupt together,
okay? Because this the system will break
down.
So, there had to be
a system
to keep the administrators loyal to the
empire.
And this system is a religion called
Zoroastrianism.
Okay, Zoroastrianism.
And this is a the religion of the
Persian people.
And this is the religion
of the
imperial administration. If you want to
be a bureaucrat within this within this
system, you have to believe in
Zoroastrianism. You have to participate
in the rituals and the rights of
Zoroastrianism.
And what made the system work is
Zoroastrianism was at this time, 600
BCE, 500 BCE,
the best religion in the world.
Okay, so this is a new concept for us,
We've discussed the best military in the
world, right? The best military in the
world has three characteristics.
Discipline, they fight a lot,
they have a lot of experience.
Cohesion, they like each other, they get
along, and devotion, they have a common
purpose, they have a great leader that
they love, okay?
It turns out religions can also be
measured.
And there's certain religions that are
better than other religions based on
three criteria, okay? These three
criteria are
grandness,
completeness,
and unity.
Okay? Grandness, completeness, and
unity.
And this is not a hard concept. So,
think of religion as a story, and ask
yourself, what makes a good story? What
makes a story so wonderful you want to
hear it? And it's these three things.
Com- grandness, it's a big topic,
kings and gods and wars and love, okay?
Completeness, there's a beginning and
there's an end.
And unity. There's a plot.
Things are united, okay?
So, if I were to tell you a story
about Gilgamesh, who's a king who fought
these gods in a search for immortality,
and in the end he discovers immortality
is impossible, well, that's a complete,
unified, and grand story.
And you would want to hear that story.
But if I were to tell you a story about
a guy named Robert who wants to get A's
in school, and so he studies all the
time, you don't want to hear that story,
okay?
It's not grand, it's very boring, it's
not complete, there's no ending, it's
not really unified because nothing
really happens.
Okay? Does that make sense?
It's the same with religions.
The problem with most religions
is the structure, okay? So, the typical
religion
is a a three-tiered structure. So, at
the center are gods.
And gods are the ones who participate in
human affairs. They're the ones
manipulating us.
But there's also a higher tier
that governs the gods as well, okay?
These are cosmic forces like
um fate and fortune.
And then the highest tier
are these invisible
laws of the universe that give it
structure, okay? What is referred to as
um the immutable
and unwritten
laws of the cosmos.
Okay? And this is what the Greeks
believed. This is what the Romans
believed.
Okay?
And as you can see,
this system,
it's not complete, it's not unified,
okay? It may be it may be grand, but
it's not complete or unified. It's a
very loose system.
Zoroastrianism is the first really
grand, complete, and unified religion,
okay? So, let's talk let's talk about um
uh Zoroastrianism.
So, in the religion, they believe
um there is a creator god, okay? Called
the Ahura
uh Mazda.
And he is the god of creation, he's the
god of light, he's the god of order. And
he creates a perfect world.
Perfection.
And within this world, we humans are
created, okay?
But then there is an evil presence, an
evil god,
which comes and corrupts the perfection.
And uh this evil or darkness
is a match for the creator god, okay?
So, the world is a perfect balance of
dark and light.
What tips the balance
is
the human race. We have free will.
Therefore, we can choose
to fight for goodness or to fight for
darkness. To fight for the truth or to
fight for the lie, okay? So, the two
main uh the dichotomy is truth and lie.
You fight for the truth, you're making
the world a better place. But you fight
for the lie, you are corrupting the
world.
Okay? So, that's our choice.
Eventually,
a savior, a hero,
will arise
to prepare for the final battle between
dark and light. In this final battle,
light will triumph.
Once
light triumphs,
a river will emerge, okay? A river will
emerge. And everyone must cross this
river.
Everyone will arise from the dead,
and everyone has to cross the river. If
you've have good, if you if you have
fought for the truth, you will cross
this river and it will cleanse you. You
will feel purified. You will become an
eternal soul who will live in paradise
forever. We'll return to perfection,
okay?
But
if in your life you have lived a lie, if
you have committed evil, if you have
done wrong against other people,
then you will burn
in the river and you'll be condemned
to hell for the rest of your life.
Okay?
And this is the idea of what we call
eschatology.
Eschatology. Yeah, okay, so this is a
hard word, eschatology, but I I I need
you guys to remember it because it's a
very important word. Eschatology means
an understanding of how the world ends.
And Zoroastrianism is the first
eschatological religion. It has an
ending.
A final battle.
Good versus evil.
Where everyone will be judged.
Okay?
And so now we we understand
why the Persian system works. Because if
you are to be an
administrator,
if you want to work for the empire, you
and you believe in Zoroastrianism, then
you have a duty to fight for the truth.
Okay? We're here at most for 60 to 80
years.
And what we do in these 60 to 80 years
will will be well decide how we live our
lives for all of eternity, okay? We
either live in paradise or we'll burn in
hell, depending on how we perform these
60 to 80 years.
So, the Persians are under tremendous
pressure to be a good person. This is
radical in the history of humanity,
okay? So, remember, the Mesopotamians
believe you are good if you achieve,
right? How do you know you're good?
Because you've achieved a lot. And by
achieving a lot, you show that God's
favored you.
And Egyptians believed in status.
And others believed in just good luck,
okay? But the Persians believed you have
to be a good person. You have to show
generosity, compassion, and mercy to
others as as exemplified by the life and
works and words of Cyrus the Great.
Okay. So, that's Zoroastrianism.
And this is so powerful that it will be
adopted into Judaism and eventually
become the basis for Christianity.
Okay? But this is where it started,
Zoroastrianism.
Any questions so far before I continue?
Are you guys clear about what's
happening?
You're like
um if this is um
the best
Okay. You know, that's a good question.
If this is the best religion, what are
the worst ones? Okay, uh you're right.
There's really no bad religion, okay?
Um but the most common religion
is
folk lord religions, right? So, so you
live in a village and you believe in a
local god.
Okay? Does Does that make sense?
Um and so, when I say it's best,
what I mean is intellectually it's the
best.
It's It's It's a religion that can
attract the best and the brightest.
Do you understand? It's It's a religion
where
um
um um if you are a very intelligent
person, you are attracted to this
religion.
Okay? Does Does that make sense. But if
you are just a normal person, you're
just going to believe what your father
and your grandfather believed.
Okay? So, think of this religion almost
as the equivalent of
the Confucian classics
in China.
How do you show cultivation in China? By
reading the Confucian classics. And if
you want to become a scholar official,
you have to memorize the Confucian
classics, right? The same concept here.
Whereas Zoroastrianism, um you have to
believe in this religion if you want to
become an administrator.
The problem with this religion that
makes it hard for people to understand
is it's very abstract.
Okay? That's the main failing of this
religion. It's very abstract. It's very
intellectual. And that's why a lot of
people don't really see this as a
religion and more as a philosophy.
It was also important important for us
to understand is
the abstraction is what makes this
religion appealing. Right? Because the
Persians are trying to attract the best
and brightest
for for for their administration.
So, they don't want a popular religion.
They're not trying to They're not
They're not trying to promote their
religion.
Okay? They're trying to use their
religion to filter out
uh the best and the brightest.
Okay?
Does that make sense? Okay? So, so
you're right. It's I can't say this is
the best religion, but it's the religion
that is the most intellectual and which
will attract uh the best administrators
in the Persian Empire. And that's why
it's effective.
Okay? Great question. Okay? Any more
questions?
The criteria of the second criteria of
effectiveness
Yes.
What is that?
Like the religion explains uh
where do people come from or where do
people come from?
Okay. So, they have completeness is
eschatology, okay? An ending.
Because most religions don't actually
have an ending.
They they don't have They don't They
don't like, "Okay, this is when the
world ends."
Okay? So, for example,
uh
um King David with That's the Bible,
right?
It's telling us that King David is
really the end of history.
And from now on, we will live forever in
this Davidic kingdom. Okay? This is the
best we can do.
But it's not saying, "Okay, King David,
um we will eventually reach a point when
the world ends
and when God returns to the Earth."
No religion is doing that before
Zoroastrianism.
Okay?
Does that make sense? Okay? So, think of
completeness as a circle, right? Because
if you look at Zoroastrianism, they say
this is a perfection, right?
But now there's corruption.
So, the story ends when when corruption
ends and we we return to perfection. The
So, the circle closes. Okay, does that
make sense? The same with the Bible
where we start in the Garden of Eden.
And then we are corrupted and we're
forced out of the Garden of Eden, right?
But nowhere does it say we will return
to the Garden of Eden.
And but when we reach Christianity,
that's what will happen.
Jesus will prom- will It Jesus is a
promise of the return to the Garden of
Eden.
Okay? So, now the circle closes.
Does that make sense?
Any more questions?
Okay. Um all right.
Let's continue.
So,
we have this religion, Zoroastrianism,
and eventually,
uh the Jews were adopted into their own
religion. Okay?
And we have Cyrus the Great who is this
wise, generous, and merciful leader,
okay? But he he is this way because he
is strategic.
Okay? He's strategic.
So,
when he allows the Jews to return to
Jerusalem, he's doing so for strategic
purposes, okay? He's not doing it
because he feels sorry for the Jews.
He's doing it because there's a certain
strategic purpose
in allowing them to return to Jerusalem.
And the reason why is Jerusalem, the
Levant, as we discussed, it is very
important geographically. It marks
access into Egypt, which is what Cyrus
the Great eventually wants to conquer
because Egypt is the wealthiest nation
in the world at this time. So, he needs
to bring stability to the Levant.
And in the in the Persian worldview,
what creates stability is the balancing
of forces within the local area. Okay?
So, he needs to create conflict in the
Levant.
At this point
in the Levant,
um
there are still Israelites living there.
And they they are now called this um
the Samaritans.
Okay?
Um
And then you have the Jews.
Okay? The Jews is a Persian word. It
means people who live in the province of
Judea, which is a Persian province,
okay? So, they're called Jews now uh and
not Israelites.
Israelites are now called Samaritans.
These come from the same people, okay?
But the difference is this. The
Israelites who stay
have adapted to new circumstances.
And so, what this means is they still
practice their religion, but they've
also intermarried with women of
different faiths. So, now it's common
for a household to practice many
different faiths.
Whereas the Jews in Babylon,
they're more fanatical.
They believe it's important to practice
only one faith.
So, when
Cyrus the Great sends the Jews
back to the Levant, this immediately
creates conflict between the Samaritans,
who believe they are the true
descendants of the Israelites, and the
Jews, who believe they are the true
descendants
of the Israelites. So, this creates
religious conflict in the Levant, which
means the Persians are able to become
the arbiter.
Okay?
And this creates divide and rule.
Now, what's important for us to
understand is
the Jews who return to the Samaritans
are only the most fanatical Jews, okay?
There's only a minority of people. The
rest of the Jews are perfectly happy in
Mesopotamia. They have very successful
careers as administrators, as
intellectuals, as teachers. They're
happy with where where they are.
Okay? So, it's only the most religious
uh extremists who return.
And they're in the minority.
The Samaritans are in the in the
majority.
So, the Persians support the Jews
who return
in trying to create purity, okay?
So, the Jews argue for purity.
Uh the Samaritans argue for tolerance.
Okay.
And so, this is a power struggle, a
religious a religious power struggle.
In
443 BCE, around then, a priest, a Jewish
priest named Ezra, he returns to
Jerusalem.
He's determined to win this war.
Okay? So, there are certain things he
does.
The first thing he does
that is extremely controversial is he
announces,
"If you are a Jewish man, you must
divorce
a foreign woman. If you're married to a
foreign woman, meaning a woman who
doesn't share our faith, then you must
divorce her in order to maintain the
purity of our people."
Okay?
He also announces that from now on, it
is mandatory for Jewish men to observe
religious rituals.
To go to temple and make a sacrifice.
Okay? So, he's trying to establish
purity.
But, his main contribution, which is the
most important, is he wants to unify
the Jewish people into one
um faction, okay? So, let me explain why
this is important.
So, as we discussed, there are multiple
Bibles out there, okay?
And so, there's at least four different
schools or four different strands.
There is the House of David school,
called the Yahwists, right?
The The Yahwists, or J.
Remember, this is um
this is the idea of the Yahwists that
the Yahweh, he is a fallible,
good-meaning, well-meaning poet.
Okay?
But, the main point of the Yahweh the
the the Yahwists is God has chosen David
to be the legitimate ruler
of Israel. God has also ordained David
to build the temple where God will
reside.
Okay? So, this is to legitimize the
authority of David and to make you
understand
the central authority of this religion
is the temple in Jerusalem.
But, as we discussed,
eventually, the northern kingdom will
break away from Judah.
But, when you once you break away, you
can't access Jerusalem anymore.
So, now you have to have other
sites where you can practice your
religious rituals, okay?
But, you do that, you have to change the
Yahweh manuscript.
And so, they do that and create a new
mythologies. This is what it was called
the E manuscript, okay? For Elohist.
Elohist is is is just a different word
for God.
Right? Does that make sense?
So, you so you have two competing
Bibles.
At the same time, you have
the priestly manuals. Okay? So,
remember,
um Judaism at this point, it is a
religion
focused on ritual, like most religions.
So, you need manuals in order to tell
you why you're doing these rituals and
how you should do these rituals. They
have to be very precise. They have to be
effective, okay?
At the same time,
as the northern kingdom fell, as Judah
was conquered by the Babylonians, as as
the Jews are forced into captivity,
you have to explain why this is
happening, okay?
And
what while this happening, most people
choose to not follow religion anymore,
okay? They adopt new religion or they
move somewhere else, okay?
But, the religious fanatics have to
explain why this happening.
And the explanation is because the
Israelites continue to disobey God.
And this faction,
uh which is basically looking at Jewish
history, explaining why this happening,
is called the Deuteronomist, okay? The D
school.
The Deuteronomist.
Okay? So, these are four major factions,
okay? Do you do you understand?
And these are four different Bibles.
Now, what actually wants to do is put
all these four Bibles together
to create the impression
of a unified religion and a unified
people.
And the way he does that, which is very
interesting, is
he basically just
takes
different parts from each of these books
and puts them together, okay?
And now this is the Bible.
And that's why if you actually read the
Bible, you'll find it completely
unreadable.
Okay? But he also makes changes to the
Bible, which is very important.
Remember, before the most important
person was David, okay? Because he's
really the founder of the nation of
Israel. He's the founder of religion.
Now, the most important person is Moses.
Because Moses is a priest. He's the one
who was given the laws
by Yahweh.
Okay? So, there are other changes
changes changes as well, but this is the
most important, okay?
There are other changes that will come
over time as Zoroastrianism merges into
Judaism, okay?
So, there are three major changes.
Um the first is the idea of eschatology.
Okay? Meaning there will be an end point
to history.
And the end point of history is when the
entire world, when all the empires of
the world, because they defy God,
converge against the nation of Israel in
one final battle.
Okay?
And this battle, of course, Israel will
win, and this will create eternal peace
in the world.
Because God has chosen Israel as his
people.
Second big idea is
um good versus evil.
Okay?
Before the religion of Judaism
was very personal.
Good and evil was in you.
But now it's there is actually good and
evil.
Okay? Israel stands for good. These
other nations, these other empires, like
the Babylonians, the Greeks, the Romans,
they represent evil.
Okay? And the third
change, and which is the most important,
is
there will be a hero who will come to
lead the nation of Israel against all
its enemies, and he is called the
Messiah, the son of man. Okay? The son
of man.
And he will come from
the house of David, as
written in the Bible.
Okay? And why is this important?
Because
the Christians believe the Messiah is
Jesus.
Okay? So, the Christians basically take
all this,
this merger of Zoroastrianism with
Judaism, and their claim is the Messiah
is Jesus.
Okay? And this creates Christianity,
which we will discuss next class.
All right?
Okay, any questions so far?
Are you guys clear about all this?
Yep.
Excuse me?
Okay.
Yeah, okay. Thanks. Thank you. Okay.
Okay. All right. So, so let me let me
explain what's happening, okay? So,
um,
remember the Babylons,
the Babylonians in 586
They take over
Jerusalem. They burn the temple. They
destroy the religion of the Jews. They
take the elite
a lot of few thousand people and they
move them to Babylonia.
Okay?
And but what's who's left behind are a
majority the majority of Israelites,
okay? But now they have to adapt to a
new elite.
And so they preserve their religion, but
they also adopt the religion of the
elite who are the Babylonians.
You will also have
Israelites
who go off to Egypt.
Okay? So so now you create something
called a diaspora.
They're either in Babylon or they're in
Egypt. But the majority are still at
home in Judea.
And in this time, because these are just
ordinary people
they will adopt many faiths. It's very
common back then for a person to have
like multiple faiths, okay? The faith of
your father, the faith of your mother,
the faith of your wife, okay? The faith
of your neighbor, okay? Because this is
how people got along. Right? If you said
that my god is better than your god
you will piss off your neighbor.
You'll piss off your colleague. Why why
would you do that? So it's very common
back then for people to have multiple
faiths. A faith you might practice at
home, a faith you might share with your
friends, a faith you might have to share
with your king. Okay? Does that make
sense?
Okay? So these are extremely multi
religious people.
As we discussed, when the Jews are when
when the Israelites are forced to go to
Babylon, they are forced to have a more
fanatical religion in order to maintain
their identity.
Right? It's like how do you separate
yourself from
these other people? Because if you don't
do that, what happens is you become
assimilated, right? You lose what it
means to be
Israelite.
And quite honestly
most people chose to be assimilated
because that's the easiest thing to do.
But there's a fanatical minority, mainly
priests, who were determined to keep
alive their religion because only by
keeping alive their religion could they
keep alive
Yahweh. Could they keep alive Israel.
Okay?
So,
when these Jews were allowed to return
to Judea, they were horrified
by the corruption and impurity they saw.
Right? They were like, "We're when
Babylon and for 70 years we fought hard
to save our religion.
To maintain the purity of our religion."
They go back and they see their people,
the Samaritans, now
adopt foreign gods.
And they were like, "This is why we
failed as a people.
This is why Yahweh punished us
because we refused to be loyal."
So, what So, what they're thinking is
like,
"I would rather all these people go away
than have them stay around.
You understand? We don't want to get
along. We want to maintain the purity of
our religion because that's the only way
to save our people."
Okay?
And that's why they say, "Hey, if you're
going to stay, you have to divorce your
wife who is a foreigner. And if you you
If you don't do it If you don't want to
do so, go away, man.
The Persian Empire is huge. Go somewhere
else. But Jerusalem is only the land of
the pure."
Okay? Does that make sense?
So,
I you know, I know this is a
controversial idea, but it's really only
the extremists who keep their religion
alive, right? This This is true for all
religions, okay? Does that make sense?
It's only people who are most willing to
die for their religion
uh that keeps their religion alive. If
everyone's willing to compromise, the
religion dies very quickly, okay? And
the Jewish religion, Judaism is able to
um, stay alive for 3,000 years because
there are lots of people in the
religion. A minority, but still a lot a
lot of people who are willing to die for
the religion. That's something we'll
discuss later on this semester, okay?
So, th- thanks for the question. Any
more questions?
Okay. So, next class, we will discuss
the rise of Christianity, okay?
Jesus, basically.